[Music]
street
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa thank you to william kerr tom
torture thursday super chat on the board
baby uh who had the best avengers member
still didn't get any credit for that i
think crow's nose was incredible you had
to be there if you missed it tom torture
thursday i wish i would have seen it oh
this is today i had a whole tongue
torture thursday last night
it's homo friday today
you guys welcome back to the break room
our daily show that keeps you updated on
all nerdy news that you need to know
coming up today tommy and brandon are
breaking down the new wakanda forever
scenes only shown to those at d23 so i
didn't see it did you see exactly i did
not okay it looks like it's exclusive oh
i couldn't talk about it then i don't
want to reveal or spoil anything for you
guys or will i oh
let's put it this way
a lot more buttholes than i thought was
oh wow
invisible that was the avatar
that was that's very active oh gosh
speaking of butt holes i'm here today
with brandon barrett
[Applause]
was gonna be blowing up a balloon don't
ever do that yeah that was me blowing up
a balloon do not uh butthole number two
tommy bechtel hey
tummy oh great to be here not guilty
don't believe what you read in the
papers the media is lying to you whoa
never done anything
oh my god and butthole number three
zack huddleston
may all your starfish be chocolate
if you if you got three bubbles you got
more problems sorry
i am
coming for me
i'm so disgusted with the boys today you
guys in honor of the many times we've
bumped our segment of andor yeah
apologies
yeah uh bless up andor uh he's dead and
to help us get hyped for its three
episode premiere next week for every one
hundred dollars we raised today in super
chats we're gonna sing an andor song
yeah we haven't sung on the show in a
while we haven't taken a while
jessica and i we have some contacts that
work at lucasfilm okay
very subversively they broke into the
offices they got us in they snuck us in
dressed as janitorial staff mm-hmm we
would never be janitors uh in real life
uh and we stole some songs that that
could be featured in android well and i
gotta say it doesn't i'm sure you've
seen the trailer and or doesn't seem
like it would be a musical but no i've
heard them practice these songs and guys
open up those checkpoints because there
are some bangers you wouldn't think
andor would be a weirdo style music
mocking show yeah but it is but it is
but the embargo is over give me camera
for it
listen to me garbage people
i know you got to go back underground
and hide from the
heating scorching rays of the sun
because you don't get enough vitamin d
pull out your wallets spend your last
five dollars to get some of these songs
going and then return to the earth where
you belong slowly decompose in your
compost piles that i assume you live in
you use the the grass clippings as
blankets maybe you make a little hat for
yourself out of a banana peel i don't
know what you do i'm rich i have two
roommates that are both adult men i'm
living good
okay but these songs are incredible and
they deserve to sing so don't let me
down absolutely also i like is compost
pile is that an upgrade from trash bag
or a downgrade it's more useful it's an
upgrade it's another it's what our more
responsible trash bags do that's right
uh hey
let's do some headlines oh what do you
guys think please do some headlines
there are some uh fun ones not gonna lie
this morning we thought it was a dry
news day but it is moistened up okay i
think the heavens have opened up yes
baby uh late breaking news this is like
within the last 20 30 minutes uh we got
some news in the sp universe the sony
pictures universe of marvel characters i
believe is with roses off the top yes
why don't they have more merch that says
spums
uh i got spumsy in thailand once
very hard
read the comments
uh so we the the next two not counting
into the spider-verse the next two
spumsy films that are confirmed uh
craven the hunter and madame webb both
got moved back now not a lot in fact
craven the hunter got moved back from
january or february january of next year
it was set to come out in just a few
months really january of 2023. and now
it will be coming out october of 2023.
so just got moved later to next year
madame when was originally going to come
out that same weekend october that
craven is now going to come out in uh
but instead that is moved to the
following february so just delayed you
know each delayed somewhere four or five
months craven still coming out before
aquaman two oh yes welcome to is coming
out in 2040. sounds to me
like they were
craving a little more time okay yes and
you know that one
no word on no word on why these delays
are happening though we know throughout
the industry especially in
uh vfx dependent films like these super
okay great problematic i can't wait to
come in a tight second on this poll um
actually if i did if i did this show
more often i'd probably have a better
chance oh no
uh
name nimei 386 uh dropping some
doubloons in the chat i think i'm
winning by seventy-five percent
sixty-nine votes
how did i get thirteen percent most
people have stained most people
liam michelle wow if you guys knew what
brandon wrote on his personal blog you
would not be thinking that's probably
what he says to me it's not open to the
public so oh sorry as i was saying right
we know a lot of including marvel with
their films lots of special effects
heavy films have been getting delayed
just because the vfx houses are all kind
of overburdened there's so many huge
movies coming out uh because so many got
delayed in the pandemic and now they're
all trying to come out at the same time
and there's literally just not enough
via marvel just moved an unnamed they've
just played around with that we don't
know what movie but they did move it
around yeah so it's still happening and
you know what we're rooting for both
these films we hope they're excellent so
take all the time you need to make a
great movie yeah sony it's normal it
happens to everyone okay sometimes your
movie's not ready it it just takes time
just give it a little more time
for movies lasting longer than four
hours please consult your doctor
problematic that's not problematic
that's medical advice that's true uh oh
in other news charlie cox has been
excitedly talking about his new
daredevil look for she-hulk uh we got a
tease of it this week but here we have a
clip of him talking about the moment he
first laid eyes on his new daredevil
look i knew i wasn't gonna wear it in
spider-man i knew that much but whilst
we were doing spider-man we were getting
ready to do she-hulk so i had to go to
la
to a fitting
and i walk in and there's the suit is
hanging there
there's a drawing on the wall
and it has the
gold and red
and i was like
no way it's funny because when you play
the character this long you like
you're you're emotionally connected to
the fans response so you see something
like that and it means something to you
but you know what it means what it's
gonna mean that you you have you start
to have a sense of how people are going
to respond to that so i saw that and
then they come in with it i'm like oh
man this is unreal
what a sweetheart um also it looks like
he just like got off the golf course and
went straight to a red carpet or
something like that maybe he's just so
used to it he's like oh i'll just jog
over how do you see it in a british
accent i guess i'll just jog on over
here
jog off is a bad thing right yeah jug
off now
jogger perhaps i'll just go on over and
do my little leg fumbles oh you're what
your leg fumbles is that running you
know they got weirdos
okay ooh looks like uh why not we'll go
ahead and do a redemption here um
brandon jessica tommy do one of you have
one of these stolen songs that we're
ready to debut yeah i mean
according to the chat i have to say
i have a little date
wait is this was it was the chat that
you have to sing or is the chat that
you're the most problematic i think i
think people got confused and they've
definitely voted in the most problematic
uh i can't believe those numbers those
guys are wild
uh
i actually wasn't there to steal some of
the songs but i did find uh uh
a post-it note in the bathroom i had
some lyrics on it and it went um
if you find a drive i'll buy it for five
so you trash to me
so you trash to me
if you have a junker i'll stuck it on my
clunker so you trash to me so you trash
to me
that was it
beautiful
beautiful thank you to uh louise
guzman-wugg andrew gibbo
yes uh well louise guzman
and all the other folks that that
contributed there uh also brad van said
you had a great english accent well
thank you brad thank you and we have i
saw in the chat earlier there's some
folks from the uk watching right now uh
so i'm sure they it sounded like they
were talking to their parents when you
just
said those lines they turned around they
thought someone was in the room
charlie come to bed now
it's past your bedtime uh
in other news griffin matthews who
played luke jacobson the fashion
designer in the most recent episode of
she-hulk uh confirmed that he will
appear in at least one other episode
this season um which that character luke
jacobson appeared three times in the
dakota north comics uh who is a private
investigator in the luke cage kind of
dead
cause we were joking like luke jacobson
what a boring name for like a fashion
designer very cool but it is a real
character from a very obscure marvel
comic i love it he appeared like three
times uh yeah was he a fashion designer
and he was a fashion designer yeah like
uh dakota knight or whatever her name
was was like very similar jessica jones
she didn't have powers she was just like
the daughter of like a cia agent she was
kind of in the loop cage daredevil world
uh but she was based in new york too so
i think luke jacobson was in new york so
i don't know why they decided to bring
him out to the west coast but he is a
real character maybe he's reinventing
himself maybe yeah
a lot of people come here to change to
get away from something or they're
running from something yes um you know
speaking of uh
griffin matthews the actor who portrayed
uh luke jacobson um he's a fresh face in
the mcu and you know what
it's fresh-faced
friday brought to you by our friends at
geology uh you might have seen i know i
the credit i was most familiar with
griffin matthews he was in the flight
attendant series on hbo finish it i
never finished i never finished it
because i got so mad i got very
so i have an issue with that actor
the
it's not that much of a spoiler the guy
who dies in the first episode i love
him yeah i didn't think i don't think
he's good in anything um
if you're out there come on the show i
think he's dutch what's his name i care
about
him
but if you're stephen
you know who i like and everything see
moolah yeah come on the show stay home
um but so uh griffin matthews and he has
a bunch of credits uh dear white people
weeds a lot of stuff um but we're happy
to see him in the mcu he's looking great
obviously he's fashionable got it got
some nice uh oh look at that head shot
some nice smooth
terubic looking skin there i don't know
how old he is but that that skin is
ageless um and you know whether you're a
fashion mogul or just a pasty white man
um trying to not look scary
on a daily live stream that's me i'm
including myself in that camp uh you
gotta go you gotta take care of yourself
you gotta keep your face hydrated
healthy smooth all that kind of stuff
and that's why you wanna check out our
friends at geology they offer a whole
range of products to keep your skin
looking its best all right you take a
little quiz you tell them what your
issues are you got a little acne you got
a little wrinkle issue maybe a little
oily whatever it is you tell them that
boom boom they give you the whole lineup
of skin care products to help you with
your issues and to keep you looking
great head over to geology.com new
rockstars and use our promo code
rockstar 70. uh to save 70 off and don't
get too comfortable because one of these
fridays we're gonna do trash based
fridays we'll feature one of you
probably uh
film juice
don't don't bring your rivalry
yeah leave your rivalries in the chat
geology.com use that promo code rockstar
70. thank you to geology um okay we had
another uh
mcu actor chatting we breed larson was
on good morning america this morning
talking about the marvels she was saying
that it differs from the first captain
marvel movie in some important ways i
think we have a clip of that interview
we're gonna roll now the first one was
the origin story of who she is now it's
digging into some more of the
complexities that there's much more to
her than that there are parts that are
not so great about her that we can see a
hero as not being the person that makes
every right decision all the time
you know that it's all about her being
in space and not coming to earth
like to help people you know that's the
is that soul reason is just her being
like i'm not really a good hero oh
interesting jessica was it you that had
the theory that she killed yeah
a little bit of me is like it is
completely a theory there isn't it's
probably untrue but i've embedded it so
deep in my head that i started to
believe it and so i was like no we all
should hate her because she killed
monica's mom and then i'm like oh wait
like accidentally giving her radiation
or whatever yes or maybe knowing or not
not necessarily knowing not trying to
kill her but maybe she knew she was
radioactive
uh well even if even if she didn't do on
purpose obviously if monica believes
that to be the case
harper's resentment not only did you
like possibly hurt my mother but you
left
uh and then you come back and you call
me lieutenant trouble in front of front
of my boss and that's not quite
trouble in front of my boss what's going
on
um
uh miss marvel that uh they're gonna be
like bickering to like train miss marvel
or like at least monic or monica and uh
kamala are actually working together and
then captain or carol danvers comes down
and is just late to the whole thing she
gets jealous because they're making
references to how i met your mother and
she hasn't watched it because she's
being blessed
it doesn't it's not necessarily
completely foreshadowing but i just
think it is nice to see like
kamala who envisioned loves captain
marvel and then captain marvel just
turns out to be a mistake or something
it'll be the same thing that monica went
through kamala's mom oh get out of here
she just keeps killing her you can't
help it she's like i'm just well i'm
proud
go ahead i don't know this important
lesson never meet your heroes looking at
you kirk gibson
toronto what did you do to her toronto
1993 a little boy with chubby hands
reached a ball into the dugout said mr
gibson can you sign this and what did
you say i don't sign on game day
why did he say that to you because he
doesn't sign on games he doesn't sign on
game day
guess what he went over for that karma's
a [ __ ] kirk um well i also liked it the
idea you know talking about the marvels
it's easy to forget carol danvers was a
fighter pilot right we all just watched
top gun maverick in the reason past
right those are cocky sometimes like uh
you know danger smirking kind of
characters you sometimes go a little
rogue right you get your little [ __ ]
that's the hard deck yeah that's right
so like she still has a little bit of
that in her right maybe she's not always
thinking about the greater good she
wants to win this battle by herself or
whatever and so that might put her in
conflict with the other characters in
that film yeah
the all that top gun maverick
it always comes back it always comes
back you can always go back to the
official movie of the break
and then weirdly i think lion king one
and a half is also our official oh we
brought that up
don't worry darling oh my god we're
clamoring to see don't worry darling
you think harry was spitting
i'm like a lizard out there spitting at
people to get tickets and speaking of
spitting we've
some of these stolen songs from andor
might have some rhymes to be spit okay
so
again in the super chats when we get up
to a threshold of uh a hundred we're a
little bit away from the next iteration
they carry the weight for everyone here
guys okay they sacrificed enough already
they died
sell some of the scraps from your
dumpsters
put a few coins in the slot uh brandon
and tommy
you were at d23 last weekend yes yes you
got to see all the exclusive footage
that they only showed there in the room
including some footage from black
panther wakanda forever yeah and we did
swear that we wouldn't reveal what that
was so let's move on
we wanted to talk about it today we made
the theme or the topic for today's video
uh great scene it was a really cool
scene uh eric has a good breakdown on
the channel you can watch about it too
but basically you see like queen
raimondo she's speaking to like the u.n
security council and they're very pissed
yeah they're kind of accusing her and
wakanda sorry no i'll go ahead of of
hoarding the assets like they're like
you're you're hoarding all the vibranium
you're purposely depriving the rest of
the world how do we know you're not
building these super weapons right to
come in like you launch some sort it's
all kind of like fantastical
fear-mongering yeah and this is also if
you remember if you put in context right
when black panther the original film
happened it's about like 2018. uh he
goes in front of the council and i was
like wakanda's open for business baby
we're gonna share our secrets with the
world uh and then the world fell apart
and then the snap happened uh in the grc
and all that so now and it's clear from
the clip we saw that like you know
t'challa is dead however they're gonna
go through that yeah and then her
husband is already dead we of course saw
that happen in some ways
yeah and so they're kind of being like
how do we know
it's cool uh and a little bit of the
patriarchy too because it's like you we
don't know if you know how to handle
this right and they bring up the fact
that like vibranium is like untraceable
it doesn't show up on scanners it can be
turned into a weapon it was turned into
ultron no no metal detectors yeah ultron
made was making a body out of vibranium
and that you know white vision is out
there somewhere flying around they don't
know where he is
uh doing something who knows what he's
doing i got a little vibranium and dr
nancy put some vibranium in me the other
week it was crazy doctor nasty puts him
in is it is it with the lemur spleen
yeah it's it's it's right i think it's
near the whale pancreas right now it's
moving around my body kind of like a
uh like a shrapnel yeah like just like
one of those cameras that they put up
your uh thing for a colonoscopy
a router tutor yeah but the other two
the other part is clipped down your
winker to your stinker from your router
to your tutor i love that i'm gonna say
that a lot the other part of this clip
that was important and interesting was
while she's kind of talking to them yeah
uh you see
uh this wakandan facility gets stormed
by these uh paramilitary group yeah they
come in and then voila the dorm alaska
are there and they capture their
military group with their vibranium
weapons like cut through guns very cool
yeah and at the end of queen raimondo's
speech they march these people and be
like yeah also we know you've already
tried yeah you're already currently
trying to steal from us and her whole
thing was like
like just to kind of retrace what you
said she the the whole speech is kind of
uh
an allegory to what's happening in real
time of like you think we're weak now
that we don't have our king
and you think we're susceptible
and and we're dangerous and we might be
panicking but what the reason why we
won't trade vibranium why we've never
traded this is we don't trust you guys
yeah and then they march them in yeah
like
we don't know who's directly sent them
no no it'll probably be america because
you know that's the kind of that's the
kind of stuff we like to do wait uh
so so so america shows up and says hey
stop trading well she's she's speaking
with the u.n security council so
america's there the representative from
france is there america the country not
american i was thinking
of that oh okay yes sorry i was united
states no no star portals were spotted
at d23 so the idea no uh the the
representative from the us too uh he
also brings up the fact that like
you guys have a he makes it seem like
you guys aren't sharing your vibranium
and we're trying to do all this uh
repatriation right the grc like that all
is still happening like they're still
trying to get people settled and back
where they need to be and they're like
hi we need your resources and it seems
like vibranium is like no
or wakanda's like no we're we're kind of
holding right now because we're dealing
with our own stuff and it's clear you
guys are trying to get our vibranium now
and that's what it is what what this
makes me think of uh with all this talk
of vibranium and how it'll be important
they're in marvel comics there are other
sources of vibranium and different like
types of it the there's the vibranium
that we know that's from wakanda there's
also like vibranium in like antarctica
because of this happening
yeah who's just saying other meteors
didn't land yes on earth or that that
meteor didn't shoot up and land other
places as well and there's like
different variations of vibranium like
the antarctic vibranium is also called
like anti-metal and sometimes it acts
the opposite of vibranium or vibranium
is perfectly resonant or whatever
absorbs all the vibrations this like
repels vibrations and can like liquefy
things by like shooting sound waves back
what happens when anti-metal and
vibranium i mean that's the you know
it's dangerous this is so insane it's
very dangerous well it's also like it's
a great device for a comic book writer
to be like my we found more vibranium
and it's different and it has different
properties so i don't know if they're
going to go into all that but i love the
idea that you know this meteorite that
hit wakanda or the area that would
become wakanda you know if it shoots it
out somewhere else and some of it landed
wherever
you know uh atlantis yes
uh ocean is you know like uh
it could be there and like you know the
the atlanteans or oceans or whatever
they're gonna call them they could be
pissed that like oh vibranium selling
or wakanda is now giving out vibranium
we have vibranium and like we don't want
them to give it out you know i think
they're that's gonna be the main
conflict is that there's gonna be a new
source of vibranium
and like that's gonna cause a lot of
problems is it oh okay so do you think
it's okay you think okay do you think
someone's creating the vibranium i don't
know if they're gonna go with the like
we made vibranium i don't like that it's
because i think once you have
the ability to make it it loses its
luster
there's nothing special about it i think
sure is up to something i don't think
like i think because i think she's
making something that uh is like a mock
version of the flower right so it's like
what if they got her hands on something
that she showed maybe they maybe
synthetic vibranium yeah well that would
be the problem right adamantium oh thank
you holy holy smokes
i had a quick question yeah in any of
this footage and a lot of what you're
describing is cool because it's it's
things we saw in the big first
trailer yeah just added to right so i'm
not seeing you not see them bringing in
the captured soldiers in the trailer you
see the like security in any of the
footage you saw we know michaela cole
has been cast in this film i think you
see like a very brief glimpse of her in
the trailer as a
what appears to be adorama lager but
like kind of her role's not been defined
and for folks that don't know she was
the creator and the star of uh i may
destroy you or whatever that series is
on hbo she's like a big time she's kind
of blowing up right now chewing up she
also created and they're like mirrors
are okay
she's probably not playing a small role
and there's been no hint at what she is
doing she was not in any of the footage
did we not get confirmation of what she
was playing maybe it could have been a
rumor i thought well they had this
special unit of the dora milaj right yes
i forget what they're called and that's
what i thought she was the leader of
yeah but that's what i'm thinking i i
thought that was the long-standing rumor
i don't know that that's been probably a
rumor i genuinely thought there's some
great comic book story lines where again
yeah they're kind of like some uh some
durham malaysia that leave and kind of
start their own thing and and there's
kind of internal conflict between those
groups so maybe we're thinking that
might be her and she's not just going to
be like the fifth dora milaje in a line
of
warriors
we'd love to offer you now unless your
kid harrington cast his uh
black
in wakanda who's like sympathetic to
neymar and there's like an inside person
uh trouble from the inside uh uh gumby
island vibes in the chat saying would
they use the dead celestial as the other
vibration i didn't even think about that
what is the celestial made out of tiamat
tmi also if like him expanding in the
earth pushed vibranium from like inside
the earth to another area or something
or maybe he disturbed uh neymar and like
that's why neymar is suddenly acting out
ocean is ian
there was the indian ocean yeah because
i was like is there going to be on that
came
i can't handle this anymore graham
you've got my attention now we're
talking about the wakanda scene the
black panther scene that they showed at
d20 it's literally the thing that's on
the thumbnail for this video do me a
favor courtney scott are you related to
graham scott slap him yeah okay oh and
also
i never looks like um we might we might
come back and keep talking uh this will
kind of forever because there's a lot to
talk about but
i think we also have to give the folks
another song stolen from disney
headquarters
it's so hard because i could talk about
everything
forever you could do this all day i
could do this all day okay so i i stole
oh no well they gave us one we got in
and i'm going to take the song and i'll
add more onto it eventually
okay i'm gonna take it and i'll put it
on my spotify oh okay um you guys can go
check it out later check out our
soundcloud so
check out my sign cloud uh that [ __ ] 22
so
the song title
is called super freaky andor oh
i did not know a song like this could
exist
this is beautiful i want this to play at
our wedding
you ready yeah stormtroopers i can kill
em i can shoot it while you flailing and
thriving i can't do any jedi tricks but
keep the forces in orbit i'm a pilot i
can fly it you go down like the climate
and every time i steal the plans i'm
always caught in a casket he want that a
n
[Music]
in this very dark uh show that tony
gilroy is playing you know yeah it
doesn't mean they can't dance at some
point
this is the song that's the flashback
or another flashback the the somehow
they're gonna look into the future yeah
yeah even serious people got to get
freaky once at all that's right thank
you to uh tony kevin brian k you capric
uh other folks oh uh one thing uh
off-screen producer john was just
reminding me so uh a little insight
again we are the actual staff of new
rockstars we all have other jobs here at
the company besides what just doing
we're in our break room yeah this is
inaudible i'm a police officer that's
right he's our company and a demolition
center that's right
most problematic that's right
okay moving on
another thing today i'm sorry i didn't
mean to scream into my mic i'm so sorry
you guys i don't think i'm responsible
for here is um i kind of distribute the
merch right you see like i'm wearing a a
cool asgard ipa shirt from epic hero
you'll see us wearing latest obsession
shirts or other kind of epic hero shirts
uh made by our partners over there at
the epic hero so i haven't told you this
i do we just got our delivery
for our andor merch
um we have okay i think some new stuff
yes this is
this just came out i
we've seen these logos but i don't think
we've seen the actual
clothing i think this is actually this
one is for you tommy zach you got that
in a baby doll size medium you know it
baby excuse me we got that shirt do you
have it in a child's house i like this
this is the death star tell me what
you're doing
tommy what are you doing with my shirt
i want to put my new shirt on
okay make them pay extra for that tell
me what's this tattoo about symmetrical
literally means nothing i worked on a
movie no one could see it tommy this one
no they're not sure
okay
all right
now
that's the main design and then uh the
one that tommy's putting on and i i have
one for each of you oh
and then my [ __ ] their
their other main design
for andor is this now
brandon how would you pronounce that uh
well i know the famous line from the
movie is what uh you rebel scum okay but
yeah what does the shirt say well it
seems like it's saying it faster than
that
like i'm gonna say something fast
well in the movie in in return of the
jedi he says you rebel scum he's
referring to them but if he were to say
it as sort of a command he would say you
rebels come
that's how he would say but i i love
this club
i'll think i'll take two ounces speaking
of not allowed on youtube i believe
these are baseball right i like this
how do you how do you make more rebels
um i do like this it's in the front i'm
going to tie 30.
it's in the fun style of the lucasfilm
graphic and it's got the little indoor
symbol built into it right there yeah
but this film doesn't have an s and a c
so close
the space
the materials good material
um so anyway nipples are humming right
now we can't show them we can talk about
them though because they're male nipples
the correct ones the god shines uh so
anyways you can check out those and they
also they have some hat designs some
other cool stuff at epic hero merch dot
com or you can get their own
newrockstarsmerch.com yeah thank you to
them for sending us those shirts we're
excited thank you so much for your shirt
thank you
you know what i needed to i needed to
express that all bodies are beautiful
and also
i want to point out thing i love your
body all right
all right
what was wrong with that is this
complimentary apology apparently it's a
chat it appears rebels come as getting
blocked in chat yeah oh wow are you just
catching this i spell it the right way
guys
r-e-b-e-l-s
big space see you out another a
paragraph just like i think you put the
big space in the wrong spot oh did i
laugh and he is stinker okay
i just think
i like that people are like friday shows
are crazy we stopped drinking for the
friday show months ago
so we're all a little punch drunk by the
time you get to the end of the week you
know it's true what were you gonna say
tommy i don't remember okay oh you know
what
i want to talk about
some nice things for once oh great we've
had a lot of profanity and obscene
images in today's show so maybe someone
needs to talk about it well guess what
that's why better help us here yeah
they've been sponsoring us all ding dong
week and we own we thank them we all
want to take care of our brains and keep
them happy and healthy and
well lubricated
one good way to do that is through
therapy but maybe you don't want to
leave your house to do therapy
thankfully our friends have better help
offer online therapy solutions i'm
telling you people
i can do this i signed up for better
help they matched me with a therapist i
had some appointments she said i have to
let the fbi know what you're telling me
during these i'm just kidding sorry
better help let's keep this appropriate
like i said before better help is online
therapy you can do it wherever you feel
the most comfortable they offer video
phone live chat online only therapy
sessions maybe get a sketch artist to
draw you and your therapist if you don't
want to do the video so you don't have
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and ain't that nice because this
economy is
stressful our listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
break room
10 off guys give yourself the gift of
mental wellness
better h-e-l-p-com
break room and do me a favor
tell them tom sent you that's right
and they'll be like who's that he'll be
like you have to say fully thomas very
unwelcome
the man whose nipples i've seen yes uh
thank you just google me you can see my
nipples you see a lot more okay
yeah your nipples have been or at least
i guess they're personally obscured on
network television haven't they not
obscured at all
basking in the glow of the midday sun
um uh thank you to better help
yes we appreciate and we appreciate
everybody that um frequents our sponsors
uses our promo codes this is believe it
or not not a cheap show to make you know
it's a bunch of people involved i get
paid a million dollars a day i know you
get a million dollars it is
unsustainable um but uh if we're it's
it's it's not a cheap show to make it so
for us to be able to bring this to you
with the high quality right like we
might all be incompetent weirdos but the
folks behind the scenes are doing a
great job daschle john everybody here at
new rockstars and so uh oh
john cut into the producer
wait grab you're leaving now
after we explained you what the show is
going to be about i will engage with you
personally in this chat for the rest of
the show
you stay there's no alcohol in our mugs
we don't have all culinary mugs water
personal questions yeah i'll say
anything you want to hear um
there was something i was gonna say oh
yeah why are you not subscribing to our
channel oh good point
hit the subscribe button hit the like
button right now everybody stop what
you're doing and hit the like button if
you have a child put the child down
abandon it for a moment yes if you're
feeding a baby or if you're feeding an
elderly no leave them aside hit the
subscribe brandon these are
hypotheticals okay they're just so sad
for these babies there's no such thing
as babies baby and the elderly i know
all right make the baby hit the like
button
baby hit like button
it's time for me
what are you whispering i can't hear it
he's whispering it's
this is the segment your parents told
you not to go home with okay it's
military fun where i get my three best
friends in the whole world who are never
judgmental and always make me feel
amazing
i know i love them they're my three best
pal
and now i get to make them have a little
fun with me and guys guess what's
happening we're
fortnight away
from marvel's first
special presentation
[Music]
that the guy who directed scored and
made we said we have to see that
it's very much in the style of the 70s
uh 80s movies of the week special
presentations and then just the kittens
whisper away from that we have the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
so we're clearly getting special around
here right marvel's getting a little
special
like you guys are special to me
okay so here's what i thought we'd do
we
5d called me last night you know we
always we always chop it up around 11
p.m he gets a little loose he's had a
couple glasses of wine he's like back
man
what's gonna be the next uh special
presentation and i said can i get my
three homies in a writer's room and
let's start pitching some ideas and he's
like i prefer you do it yourself man you
cook best alone i said no
these are my three best friends so what
i want you guys to do
is give me your pitch i want the title i
want the log line and then i'd like you
to do a little acting
okay
and then i've seen i'm gonna go first oh
okay okay
all right so you guys can see like the
standard he's
he's modeling the behavior he wants to
see oh we got props okay yeah i didn't
know we were supposed to have i didn't
know where i was
john we can't
my belly button's forbidden uh
i i am very excited
to introduce you guys uh to
the next marvel special presentation
thor's
mighty thanksgiving mukbang
where odin's son will enjoy all of the
thanksgiving treats and treasures pies
cakes
turkey corn mashed potatoes dinner rolls
creamed spinach regular spinach
cranberry sauce
regular cranberries ocean spray
cranberry juice sweet peas
bitter peas dill pickles sweet pickles
cucumber salad a little black tar heroin
what
well that's just my family
oh sorry don't do that
uh and then let me give you a little
preview of what it's gonna look like
okay this is like a clip from the
trailer kind of thing is that a thong on
yeah no this is from yesterday's show
when thong made an appearance
it's the avengers oh well there will be
easter eggs in these special
presentations this is easter egg so this
is our avenger the thong all right
whoa what a beautiful bounty of
delicious foods why i see cakes
i see pie
turkey
corn
mashed potatoes
cream spinach regular spinach now we get
into the cranberry sauce whole
cranberries ocean spray
a very handsome man with
suspiciously large bulge in his pants
approaches a dinner table
he looks at it like he's looking at the
most beautiful woman in the world and
then he begins to shove it all in his
face that's a lot of rebels gum
again thor's mighty thanksgiving mukbang
the log line is thor goes ham on a ham
in turkey for thanksgiving in turkey in
turkey and it actually takes place
in a very problematic portion of turkey
that is funding uh somehow you want to
get into it all right it's getting worse
well i'm going to north korea next month
guys to play basketball with rodman
uh brandon you
yeah i had an idea you were pretty
excited i think it's time that uh you
know marvel's picks aside okay this is
gonna be a marvel studios jesus this is
a marvelous
special presentations
uh and this one is for easter baby and
the title is called he is risen whoa
this is the tale of light magic within
the mcu while marvel introduces the
first mutant jesus
that's right marvel is going to
establish jesus christ of nazareth as a
as a mutant he walks on water folks yeah
maybe he can manipulate the matter of
both bread and fish multiplying it and
and water and water well you can turn
water into wine but any magician could
do that we saw we saw uh stephen strange
do that it's not a good trick he can
heal the lame well he can create an army
of the dead
the
yes
of necromancy folks uh uh you know and
that's that's gonna be his powers it's
gonna be a variety show i can't i can
see people in the chat i understand
jesus sounds op
jesus is open if you thought if you
thought captain marvel was open wait do
you meet jesus christ i just have a hard
time latching on to this jesus character
because they seem unstoppable yeah you
can't stop you can't stop jesus and he's
here for you philistines he's going to
take you out let me tell you something
once you let him in your heart you'll be
unstoppable yeah that's right good point
i could see his um then do we meet his
nemesis
pilot
and he's a and he's a world war ii
fighter pilot
he was frozen in the stand
he crashed into tunisia got stuck in the
sand travel back through time wow
brandon i got it hands you you let me
read an early draft of this
what was jesus catch phrase again it was
he said it's morphin time that's right
he was the original one to say it's
morphin not mormon i don't know
morphine time had a really weird factor
heroin is in yours yeah jesus morphs
into a 50-foot tall man wow
devour
you know disney plus plays with these
ratings what are you thinking for this
nc-17 uh this is tvma wow
smoking yeah wow like passion of the
yeah he has risen okay no one knows that
christianity started as a mushroom cult
they will be doing mushrooms
okay
um everyone knows that
do we need to do every single one of
them knows that do we need to revisit
that who's the most problematic no uh
definitely still me jessica you had a
nice pitch i remember yeah but i
remember yours is nice
this is you know both uh tommy's uh
special presentation sounds you know
tactile very visceral
kind of gross yeah mine's going to be in
4d yes smell-o-vision even uh brandon
sounds this is high concept big vfx
mine's different okay mine's almost like
a bottle episode it's gonna be intimate
okay it's some of uh it's for
valentine's day oh okay special baby
valentine's day presentation and it's
just um
hey do you know what i might pull out no
no no no no no
it's very effective most of the time
saw me um we gotta talk after this my my
valentine's day special is called pepper
potts
a new love okay
and so we this is set in the modern mcu
right has been dead she's alone pepper
is alone a single mom right out there
looking for love maybe a little bit like
she-hulk we see her you know scrolling
the apps no i'm i'm i'm too busy for
that i'm rich i don't want to be honest
no even raya is low class for her
so she realizes like
i had a true love and i can have him
back what how
the ai right
we've got all these iron man suits all
these recordings right all this kind of
stuff so in a um a jarvis or a what was
the one from um uh uh far from home
edith edith right style she uh embodies
she embodies a uh tony stark ai into an
iron man suit okay uh brandon i think it
was you you added under this picture
and um
she [ __ ] the robot
she makes a sex robot
that's wonderful
in my head cannon to support this story
pepper is lonely during the events of no
way home uh and she's about to call up
peter parker for a little bit of you oh
no a little bit of cougar
wow just as she goes down the number the
spell goes through and she she was like
who was i gonna call i don't know oh
at the end of the stream to be the we
update the poll who's probably
great
the goal of this entire episode is can
we change the order of the uh that's a
great tie-in too to have the the spell
hey he can be 18 in high school
whoever's running by the way rock stars
if pepper is stressed out about dating
apps you can always try my app guys
right now i'm offering breaking
listeners 59 off for a one month
subscription thrust okay
i can't believe you're doing side deals
my dating app god damn it it's not i'm
sorry i'm not part of the show folks the
rust
you gotta say like that you gotta go to
the special url it's voiceless
you know what a lot of people are
meeting the loves of their lives on
frost
we're encouraging this horrible behavior
okay slide into my dms this weekend it's
cold in my head my my i have uh i
pitched this to disney and they said
that they greenlit already so this is
wow congratulations it's called a very
big woman break room please
why would you say that hannah
i will call my mom and we'll call anna
and i'll call angelica and we'll just
hang out um so
it's called a very barren president's
day
and baron zemo just killed our president
oh
my god
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry this is just the
pitch
hey yo hey yo
you see zemo in the yard best believe
he's going hard hey yo
it's emory
zemo is thrust
he's the face of thrust
he's matching and hatching plans
clapping cheeks and
peeling sneakers
oh sneakers topical for this week's
episode
is my drift broker you better believe it
i'm dropping a new line of shoes i
pitched up my breakdown that he's the
drip broker
he has his assembled episode where he
has sukovia and i was like watch him be
the drip broker that would be incredible
oh my god
tell us more about your projects i'm so
sorry are you supposed to please
maybe move tommy's mic is it olympus has
fallen kind of thing where there's like
a siege at the white house yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah tim and his goons taking
over the white house now
and um
none other than valentina uh
showing up okay to try and dethrone him
she turns out to be the vice president
oh
okay i like that um i pitched in i was
like it's like but crazy right and they
were like what's crazier than veep and i
said this show
because it's sponsored by thrust
yeah we are i would like to announce we
are the official sponsor of a very
barren president's day
we're very excited and right now if you
use the code
thrust it so hard it breaks
you'll get 98 off
of an infinity subscription
forever yeah you only paid two percent
now what's that promo card thrust is so
hard it breaks
you don't know what i'm talking about i
can be talking about a boxing glove
wow
his mother could be watching you you
also said that she hulk's like uh she
holds dating page where she she was like
i'm gonna break your back out yeah so
yeah so that that's the show or that's
the it's called a very barren
president's day
uh tagline uh baron
is coming to kill your president
something wow and take me out to dinner
take me out to dinner uh and you want me
to act it out a little bit yeah i'd love
to yeah i wish i had a ski mask because
it's him with the skin oh
yes let's get there so he comes in and
he does
and he distracts oh he's doing this it
distracts joe enough and then he goes
and then why is that just joe poor it's
the president well they got a new
president yeah dylan mcdermott or
whatever his name is
my thing is more authentic if it's true
oh wow
i strive for authenticity yes
always thank you to everybody uh sending
super chats bucky barnes atl zack brad
at braddock td jones it's morphing time
yes not morphing time uh quentin mutant
jesus versus mutant ganesh that could be
good
that's the that's eternals two we gotta
save that plot for eternals too uh mike
cairo in the chat said is werewolf by
night a cinematic movie within the mcu
starring asgardian actors
incredible i like that we need to get
you on rogue theory yeah yeah i want to
see the asgardian actors show up and
wonder wonder man that's what i'm hoping
i i i'm sorry i didn't mean to interrupt
you what you're saying is is appropriate
and not safe for the show i have to
dispel some rumors that are going on oh
thrust is not a hookup app no thrust is
for a meaningful relationships you don't
download it's designed to be deleted
it's designed for your phone to be
thrown into the ocean you meet the love
of your life and you hurl your phone off
the santa monica pier
just steps away someone said no it's
thrusting time no no tell me though i
know like thrust has a sister app that
isn't purely
just for the ladies oh i was gonna say
it's just that it's just sex horrible oh
yeah yeah yeah there is there is just a
there is a hookup app yeah and it's
called band
just so you guys know banged wired
magazine when they were asked about bang
said
my favorite bit that you love to go back
to is
[Applause]
i don't have a lot of jokes i'm not very
talented why would you call them out
like that
i gotta
and then i get on and i'm like god damn
it
i do uh we did get a super chat thank
you the the mods for their hard work
today i do want to say freight girl did
call out uh she wanted to update on the
fantasy scores we don't have that today
we'll have the updates next week before
next episode yeah sure guys rocket ship
for the champions
league thank you
but we will update for the fancy drafts
and we're already talking about the
problematic oh wow did we get a
different order
[Music]
uh we are we're gonna try uh we're gonna
do predictions for andor which starts
next week uh we're gonna do a slightly
different format we're working on that
but we've got some really uh fun cool
stuff prepared for that can we do
another song i know we haven't gotten to
300
yeah
okay we could do another nicki minaj
gets two songs wow uh at least two songs
on andor uh
you know if you're young you know
uh your kids are gonna love it folks um
if you know super bass this is also
called super bass oh but it's b-a-s-e oh
my gosh
we know the super bass in the star wars
universe here we go this one is for the
rebels with the booming system top-down
axe with the laser system when he come
up in the station he'd be blazing up got
ties on deck like he's saving up yeah
he's sit he darth he might got a heart
he fly shuttle's letting the other right
kind of guilt he course he hoarse he
might use the force he always in space
but he never off course he's the
[ __ ]
on the ship when you make a blip flip
kiss him on the liverpool that's the
kind of moth i was looking for whoa and
yes i'll go off if you look at her
excuse me you're a rebellion guy i mean
mama mama you're like mon calamari and
fly i mean you're so shy and i'm loving
jedi you know i feel good with this guy
what's your son's flying by oh yes i did
yes i did somebody please tell who the
mother is i am palpatine i mack the rebs
up back ties up and chuck the sith up
boy you got my alderam blowing away
killing all those rebels and i'm coming
your way
on top of that because that was i think
his name is dylon dylan
if you're listening colin
dylan with the stimulus that was
incredible
that was incredible
there were a lot of words in that brain
a lot of great star wars references even
at the top with the pronunciation of at
at very nice
what about mine it had a bunch of things
earlier listen let's be honest those
were great mine was very phoned in
and zach didn't even do his homework
that's right i did the audience a favor
we couldn't have him
um
thank you all so much for joining us
we're on the threshold
one more episode and then our 100th
episode what is the 100th episode is
that wood or diamond what are we getting
each other oh i believe it's super chat
what kind of wood oh funyuns i can't
count on them funyuns yes i want a
funyun ring
to wear
yeah next tuesday will be our 100th
episode of a few little special
surprises i think yeah yes please come
back
if you like please come back there's a
rumor that the pope will be here no if
you liked this episode come back for the
100th if you hated this episode come
back for that go back and face us you
cowards please and subscribe you little
[ __ ] please don't let the pope come
on this show after my jesus stuff oh
he's coming on two addresses
i actually called him right after oh no
the probe's here oh no no
the pope's here for a special hundred
percent he's like a great guy uh all
right well uh i think that concludes
everything did we want to do our quick
uh
shout outs things we're enjoying and
watching yeah
it's a friday we watch a lot of marvel
star wars all day
the house of the dragon rings of power
stuff here is there anything else that
you guys have been enjoying any content
you've been consuming any movies you
want to give a shout out to that are
good and you want people to watch
is there anything else you've been
enjoying in this world
oh i have a quick one i'll just throw it
out real quick um while you're watching
house of the dragon or whatever on hbo
max there's an animated series on there
called primal gandy tarkovsky
that is so good i think it's either the
second season is about to wrap up that
show is so good watch that show i like
that i like that what if i you know what
i've been doing this is like comfort
food for me although it's you know it
can trigger some sad emotions i've been
going back to the bourdain catalog
loving i love life it's so fun to just
follow him through all those those
locations especially the older ones he's
young and not young but younger and
you know he's just he's smoking like a
chimney
using his body and he's doing like
indonesia for the first time that's all
i've ever won he's getting spumsy from
indonesia it's crazy
a lot of rebels come from there i'll
follow tommy's because i actually have
been watching i've been re-watching
every cooking channel or like every
cooking show by maddie madison uh
because i love maddie manson and i
killed madison so it's fun
didn't love that he gave himself a job
on the bear as an executive producer
maddie too many cooks in the kitchen
yes chef
pinocchio love pinocchio uh and i i will
i will promote something that zach
recommended to me that i really liked a
little little television show on the fx
if you have hulu you probably have it
too the old man yeah jeff bridges
this weekend that was surprisingly very
good i call it memories and monologues
baby uh it's it's well written well
active very good stuff love to see my
boy jeff that was right almost took him
but we kept them on this iron monkey
himself the the original of a box of
scraps yeah
he says it's 10 times on the old man
look out for it
i rewatched it and i was like iron man
and i was like holy [ __ ] i forget that
this is where we grabbed it from yeah it
just now flies over my head yeah but i
love it bring back obadiah staying in
cowards
we got we got about 45 seconds throw it
in the chat what you're watching i see
people saying arcane and what the hell
what's up with our
oh my
all our uk viewers fell asleep half an
hour ago so that's all right uh thank
you all so much thanks for watching have
a great weekend everybody we'll be back
next week join us on monday not happen
no okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
street
[Music]
you